llegan más promesas a favor del medio
ambiente por parte de los líderes
mundiales en el marco de la cob 26 un
centenar de países se suma a eeuu y la
unión europea para reducir hasta el 2030
un 30 por ciento de la producción del
gas metano uno de los principales
responsables del calentamiento global
sin embargo australia ha rechazado la
propuesta y los grandes emisores de
metano rusia china e india- no han
firmado
mismas todavía quedan dos semanas de
negociación detallada debemos cuidarnos
de las falsas esperanzas y no pensar de
ninguna manera que el trabajo está hecho
porque no lo está todavía queda un largo
camino por recorrer pero dicho esto soy
cautelosamente optimista
optimistic limitar el calentamiento
global a 1,5 grados centígrados ha sido
un reto aceptado por países como
colombia china e india- aunque no todos
aceptaron cumplirlo para el plazo fijado
el año 2030 países como brasil república
democrática del congo e indonesia que en
conjunto representan el 85 por ciento de
bosques del mundo se han comprometido a
detener y revertir la deforestación para
el final de la década una meta
respaldada por 19 mil millones de
dólares en fondos públicos y privados
reconocemos que nuestra tecnología
actual por sí sola no nos llevará a
donde debemos estar por lo que también
debe ser una década decisiva para la
innovación el desarrollo y la
comercialización de nuevas tecnologías
para el 2030 actuar en ferrari para
cumplir el objetivo de financiación de
los países ricos hacia aquellos en
desarrollo apoyo comprometió este martes
a aportar con 10 mil millones de dólares
en cinco años y aunque las promesas
económicas son muchas los 100 mil
millones de dólares anuales fijados para
el año 2020 han fracasado la nueva meta
económica se cumplirá con miras al 2023
según informó el presidente de la cumbre